نفى الرئيس التنفيذي لبطوله كاس العالم
ناصر الخاطر بشده التقارير التي نشرتها
بعض الصحف الانجليزيه والفرنسيه التي
تزعمت ان البلاد دفعت اموالا الى العماله
الاسيويه لحضور فعاليات كاس العالم
كمشجعين
صحف انجليزيه وفرنسيه بالتحديد بخصوص
استئجار عماله اسيويه انه يكونوا مشجعين
لمنتخبات عاريه عن الصحه تماما
اولا هذه محاوله اخرى للتشويه محاوله اخرى
للتشكيك بقدره خطر على استضافه بطوله كاس
العالم همم طبعا همم
شرف استضافه بطوله كاس العالم يعني كان في
محاولات مستمره على 12 سنه او 13 سنه في
هذه البطوله احنا متعودين على على هذا
الكلام احنا همم ان شاء الله راح ننظم
بطوله استثنائيه في وقت قريب ان شاء الله
بعد خمس ايام همم لكن المحزن في هذا الامر
التقليل من فئه من الناس موجودين على ارض
قطر مقيمين
بعضهم بالثلاثين والاربعين سنه اااه
بالتقليل من منهم انهم عماله ماجوره ان ان
يحضرون بطوله كاس العالم اولا بطوله كاس
العالم تنبيع 3.1 مليون تذكره الى حد الان
ااا احنا عندنا المقيمين في قطر في منهم
شغوفين بكره القدم بشكل كبير اااه طبعا
ناكد ان هذه التقارير عاريه عن الصحه
تماما واحنا يعني همم نوجه رساله لكل
المقيمين على ارض قطر ان هذه البطوله
بطولتكم هذه بطوله الجميع هذه بطوله تمثل
قطر بشعبها بمقيمتها بمواطنيها وايضا لدول
الخليج والمنطقه الاكبر